Wenn wir uns mal wirklich realistisch
angucken, dass 100 Konzerne für 71 Prozent
der Treibhausgasemissionen
weltweit verantwortlich sind, ist es nicht
mein Burger Patty, meine Plastikzahnbürste
oder irgendwie meine Reise nach Italien,
die für die Klimakrise verantwortlich
ist, sondern es sind diese 100 Konzerne,
die für 71 Prozent der Emissionen
verantwortlich sind.
Herzlich willkommen. Heute geht es um's
Klima. Oder anders gesagt: Es geht
um alles, um unser aller Existenz.
13 Fragen, hier kommt Frage Nummer 1: Sind
Verbote eurer Meinung nach das letzte
Mittel, diesen Planeten zu retten?
Wenn ihr sagt, eher ja, dann
bitte auf dem grünen Feld positionieren.
Und wenn ihr sagt, nee, da gibt's
noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten, dann bitte
auf dem gelben Feld positionieren. Und bitte.
So, jetzt wissen wir buchstäblich,
wo ihr steht. Aber wo steht ihr eigentlich?
Spätestens seit dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes Ende
April wissen wir ja, wir müssen in Sachen
Klimaschutz schneller werden,
zumindest schneller als bisher politisch geplant,
damit die Leute in zehn, zwanzig,
fünfzig Jahren nicht viel härtere Einschnitte
erleben müssen als Leute heute. Also
dass wir etwas ändern müssen, darüber herrscht
Einigkeit. Die Frage ist: Wie ändern
wir etwas? Wie geht es euch? Würdet ihr eher
auf die grüne Seite gehen und sagen:
wir brauchen harte Einschnitte, wir brauchen
mehr Verbote? Oder würdet ihr sagen,
im Gegenteil, wie die gelbe Seite,
mehr Eigenverantwortlichkeit,
andere Anreize. 13 Fragen, jetzt geht's los
mit diskutieren. Grundsätzlich gilt,
wenn ihr im Laufe dieser Folge der Gegenseite
in einem Punkt zustimmt, dann dürft
ihr gerne auf sie zugehen, das heißt einfach
einen Schritt nach vorne gehen.
Wenn ihr sagt, grundsätzlich finde ich ja
deine Position gar nicht so blöd, aber
was du jetzt gerade erzählst, ist totaler
Schwachsinn, dann könnt ihr auch gerne
einen Schritt zurückgehen. Mein Ziel
am Ende dieser Folge ist es,
möglichst viele von euch hier in der Mitte,
im sogenannten Kompromissfeld zu versammeln.
Denn diese Sendung versucht ja
vor allem Kompromisse und vielleicht
sogar Konsens herzustellen und weniger
nur ein bloßer Schlagabtausch zu sein.
Das ist das Ziel dieser Sendung. Mal sehen,
wie weit wir kommen und wie weit ihr kommt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Wir legen
jetzt los. 13 Fragen, hier kommt
also jetzt Frage Nummer 2 und die stelle
ich an Carla: Du bist "Fridays for
Future"-Aktivistin. Warum glaubst du,
-sind Verbote der richtige Weg?
-Ich glaube, wir müssen uns zuallererst
klar machen, um was für Verbote
es eigentlich geht. Es geht hier nicht
um das symbolische Verbot von einer Plastiktüte
oder die Plastikzahnbürste,
sondern es geht um die Frage z.B.
insbesondere im Bereich Technologien:
Was sind Technologien, die wir uns
noch erlauben können in einer klimagerechten
Zukunft? Und da gibt es eben Sachen
wie ein Verbrennermotor oder die Verstromung
von Braunkohle, die wird es in einer klimagerechten
Zukunft,
wo wir ohne Emissionen
wirtschaften wollen, nicht mehr geben können.
Um die Klimakrise zu bekämpfen, müssen
wir jetzt effizient und schnell Emissionen
senken. Das werden wir nicht
tun, indem wir auf den Markt setzen
oder nur an die Vernunft
appellieren, sondern es braucht konkrete Verbote,
insbesondere auf Unternehmensseite,
die immer noch für die meisten Emissionen
verantwortlich sind. Wir haben es gesehen
beim Atomausstieg, da hat man es auch so
gemacht. Das war der richtige
Schritt. Und genauso ist es bei der Frage
-in der Klimakrise auch.
-Ist doch plausibel oder, gelb? Ich frag
mal Richtung gelb rüber,
Philipp geht schon nach vorne.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, dass ist
sehr plausibel. In meinem Bereich sehe
ich die Sachen ein bisschen anders.
Im landwirtschaftlichen Bereich gibt's ganz
viele Leute, die wirklich etwas machen
wollen gegen den Klimawandel
und die im Moment durch
bestimmte Regelungen, die es jetzt gibt,
total eingeschränkt sind. Und daher glaube
ich nicht, dass wir dort mit weiteren
-Verboten in die Richtung weiterkommen.
-Du, der nun unter anderem bei einem
Automobilriesen arbeitet, wirst
wahrscheinlich sagen, Verbrenner verbieten
-finde ich doof. Was würdest du also sagen?
-Ich meine das Beispiel, was du gebracht
hast, mit dem Atomausstieg, ist ja
ein sehr gutes. Dass wir so weit sind,
dass wir nächstes Jahr das letzte
Atomkraftwerk vom Netz abschalten.
Aber dadurch, dass du aus der Atomkraft
aussteigt, ist ja keine Windkraftanlage,
kein Solarpanel gebaut worden. Ich meine,
wir müssen den Fokus mehr auf Innovation
legen. Wir sollten mehr über das reden,
wo wir hin wollen, welche Rahmenbedingungen
wir setzen, wie die Infrastruktur
von morgen aussieht. Mir ist es zu einfach,
zu sagen, wir fahren nicht mehr mit Verbrennerautos,
sondern ich würde gerne
über das Andere reden und das ist
die Elektromobilität. Und wir müssen jetzt
darüber sprechen, wie wir dort
schnell Laden so ermöglichen, dass es sich
für Menschen anfühlt wie Tanken. Und dann
glaube ich, hast du eine Alternative,
dass die Menschen ein attraktives
Produkt kennenlernen, dass sie das schätzen
und dass sie dann merken,
ja, das ist der bessere Weg.
-Pia, glaubst du auch?
-Ja, total. Aber es geht ja nicht darum,
dass wir nur Verbote brauchen und dass alles
andere nichts nützt. Ich finde auch,
dass genau das, was du sagst -
Anreize schaffen, vor allem auch unterstützend
wirken - sei es in der Wirtschaft, sei
es aber auch bei Privatpersonen - ist total
wichtig. Ich glaube, dass wir früher
oder später Verbote brauchen, weil es gerade
nicht darum geht, das Klima oder die Umwelt
zu retten, sondern Menschenleben
zu retten. Menschen davor zu retten,
zu ertrinken, zu verhungern,
ihre Lebensgrundlage zu verlieren
und am Ende auch ihr Leben zu verlieren.
Okay, das heißt, da gibt's schon eine gewisse
Kompromissbereitschaft, aber dir
geht es zu langsam. Deswegen sagst
du, im Zweifel muss halt das Verbot her. Hab
ich das richtig
verstanden? Überzeugt dich das?
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben über
Verbote eine sehr polarisierte Debatte.
Und das Problem ist, sobald dann
jemand sagt, wir müssen was verbieten,
kommt gleich Reaktanz, gleich
Gegenwehr und man unterhält sich überhaupt nicht
mehr über das Problem eigentlich, um die Ursache
des Problems vor allen Dingen.
Das Problem mit Verboten ist, wenn sie pauschal
sind, verstehen Menschen nicht,
was das mit ihnen zu tun hat. Sie fühlen
sich ungerecht behandelt, weil andere,
die vielleicht Verursacher des
Problems sind, weniger durch die Verbote betroffen
sind. Wir brauchen eine Diskussion
über Grenzen, über planetare Grenzen,
Grenzen des Wachstums und über Grenzen
der individuellen Handlungsmöglichkeiten.
Yasemin, du bist gleich nach vorne
gelaufen, hab ich gesehen.
Ich stimme ihr zu, dass das Wort
Verbote für viele sehr provokant ist und Menschen
überfordern kann. Wenn man
Alternativen zeigt, was man anstelle machen kann,
dann finde ich es richtig. Aber
viele Menschen haben wahrscheinlich
mit dem Begriff Verbot ein Problem
und nicht mit der Umsetzung. Leider sind
Verbote notwendig, da wir sehen, dass Menschen
nicht freiwillig klimafreundlich
handeln. Deswegen müssen politsche
Verbote, Maßnahmen oder Regelungen kommen,
-damit wir unseren Planeten retten können.
-Aber du sagst vollkommen zurecht, das Wort
Verbot löst eine Reaktanz
aus. Also würdest du was vorschlagen?
Wenn ich z.B. verbiete, dass sonntags
Auto gefahren wird oder an bestimmten Uhrzeiten
Auto gefahren wird, dann greift das ein Symptom
an, nämlich viel Autofahren.
Es greift nicht an der Ursache an,
nämlich dass wir Infrastrukturen haben, in denen
Autos einfach bevorzugt werden, in denen
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel nicht
zur Verfügung stehen. Das heißt
also, wir müssen eigentlich an den Ursachen
ansetzen. Und ich glaube, da brauchen
wir strengere Ziele, wir brauchen
ambitioniertere Ziele, wir brauchen
kurzfristige Ziele, also
mit 5-Jahres-Horizonten
arbeiten und nicht 15 oder 20 Jahren.
Und jetzt die Frage an euch: Hat euch
das, was Melanie gerade erzählt hat, überzeugt?
In Teilen seid ihr nach vorne
gegangen. Ist es der richtige Weg? Warum gehen
-wir den dann nicht?
-Also gerade der Punkt mit den
kurzfristigeren Zielen ist, finde
ich, einen sehr relevanten Punkt, den du
da gebracht hast. Denn was wir bisher
in der Klimapolitik erleben, sind viele mehr
oder weniger inhaltsleere Fernziele.
Wenn wir über Klima Neutralität 2050 sprechen,
was die Bundesregierung lange gemacht
hat, dann ist das kein Ziel, was wirklich
substantiell etwas zum Klimaschutz
beiträgt. Wir brauchen jetzt sozusagen
kurzfristige Planungshorizonte. Auch gerade
im Bereich der Wirtschaft, damit
es da eben Anreize gibt, zu sagen,
okay, wenn wir wissen, in fünf Jahren gibt's
keine Verbrennermotoren mehr
beispielsweise, gibt es einen Anreiz,
viel mehr dann in E-Technologie
etc. zu investieren, da zu forschen.
Und deswegen ist es eben so wichtig,
dass wir Klimaziele für 2025, 2030, 2035 haben.
Denn genau das ermöglicht uns
dann, sozusagen zu gucken, wie können
-wir das als Gesellschaft möglich machen.
-Philipp, bist du gerade zurückgelaufen?
-Ich bin gerade zurückgelaufen, ja.
-Warum?
Ich glaube, dass es vielmehr
darum geht, eine Kultur zu schaffen,
in der wir auch solche
langfristigen Ziele wirklich bei den Menschen direkt
verankern. Wenn jetzt gesagt wird,
wir brauchen ganz kurzfristige Verbote,
das ist total anfällig für Populismus.
Das kann die nächste Regierung wieder kippen
oder die nächste Mode auch. Aber wenn wir eine Kultur
verankern, in der es, sag
ich mal, belohnt wird, dass langfristige
Ziele wie z.B. Klimaneutralität verfolgt
werden, auch im Alltag, dann ist es wirklich
nachhaltig. Weil alle merken,
hey, wenn ich mich so verhalte, dass die nächsten
Generationen hier noch leben
können auf dem Planeten, dann bin
ich anerkannt, dann bin ich in der Mitte
der Gesellschaft, da erfahre ich Wertschätzung.
Und wenn ich Wertschätzung
habe und mich wohlfühle, dann
brauche ich kein dickes Auto fahren.
Also Philipp schlägt vor, einen
Kulturwandel, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
-Yasmine, überzeugt ich das?
-Ja und nein. Ich denke, wenn man den
Menschen genau sagt, hey, was ist das Problem,
was ist die Ursache, was können
wir machen? Dann können wir,
glaube ich, wirklich jeden auf dieser Erde
für Klimaschutz aktivieren. Aber
ich glaube, dass diese Kultur zu schaffen,
braucht Zeit, viel
Zeit, und die haben wir nicht.
-Jetzt gehst du wieder vor.
-Ja.
-Du widersprichst dir selbst.
-Nein, ich finde das sinnvoll. Was sie
gesagt hat, ist, dass es Zeit braucht.
Das stimmt und da stimme ich zu, auf jeden
-Fall. Deswegen gehe ich nach vorne.
-Aber sie sagt auch, die Zeit haben wir
-nicht.
-Ja, das stimmt auch.
Jetzt weißt du nicht
genau, ob du vor oder zurück sollst.
Ja, das ist so, manchmal
müssen wir vor- oder zurückgehen.
-Vollkommen legitim.
-Also wo fange ich mit Verboten an oder wo
können wir es sein lassen? Das ist
eine schwierige Frage auf jeden.
Aber genau diese Grenze versuchen
wir jetzt gerade auszuloten. Also Daniel,
-was ist deine Antwort?
-Ich glaube, wir brauchen sowas wie
Berechenbarkeit auf der einen
Seite, dass die Leute wissen, welches Ziel
wir wann erreichen und wie auch,
dass wir so was brauchen wie Akzeptanz.
Und deswegen sollten wir aus meiner
Sicht sehr sorgsam damit umgehen und uns gut
überlegen, wie wir diese Transformation
gestalten. Weil es ist mehr
als nur Klimaschutz. Es geht auch um die Frage
von persönlichen Freiheiten, das hat
das Bundesverfassungsgericht
geurteilt, dass Klimaschutz und Freiheit, das steht
nicht mehr irgendwie so, sondern das ist
eins. Auf der anderen Seite geht
es um die Frage von Wohlstand. Es geht
darum, dass Menschen ihren Arbeitsplatz
behalten. Vielleicht geht es auch darum,
dass wir neue Arbeitsplätze schaffen. Ja,
du hast Recht, wir brauchen,
Carla, diese kurzfristigeren Ziele
im 5-Jahres-Rhythmus, dass man
sie überprüfen kann. Wir dürfen aber
auch nicht davon ausgehen, dass wir die Technologie,
die wir 2030 oder 40 oder 50
haben, dass das das ist, was wir heute
haben. Wir werden Sprünge haben,
also werden wir besser werden. Jeder
kann sich noch an den Moment im Jahr 2005
erinnern, als er ein Nokia-Handy in der Hand
hatte und drei Jahre später hatte
er ein iPhone gehabt und keiner
wusste damals, was ein Smartphone ist. So wird
es bei der Batterietechnologie sein, so
wird es aber bestimmt auch, was Stromnetze
betrifft, und so wird es auch,
was den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
-und die Effizienz betrifft, sein.
-Carla hast du damit aber nicht überzeugt.
-Warum nicht?
-Also wenn ich mir angucke, wo wir in
Deutschland gerade stehen, dann haben
wir ein CO2-Budget, also die Menge an CO2,
die Deutschland noch ausstoßen darf, um einen
gerechten Beitrag zur Einhaltung des
1,5-Grad-Ziels zu leisten. Das kann
man ja von dem weltweiten CO2-Budget
runterberechnen auf Deutschland. Wenn wir uns
das angucken, wo wir gerade sind,
dann haben wir nicht einmal mehr sieben
Jahre. Also in nicht mal sieben Jahren ist
es aufgebraucht, wenn wir so weiter
emittieren wie bis jetzt. Und da möchte
ich mich als Person, die Leute kennt,
die schon jetzt von den Folgen der Klimakrise
betroffen sind, als auch die weiß,
dass ich in der Zukunft, 2050, 2060,
das vermutlich noch erleben
werde, mich nicht verlassen auf irgendeine
Technologie, die vielleicht kommt,
aber vielleicht auch nicht, auf irgendeine
Effizienzsteigerung, die vielleicht
kommt oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich sage nicht, dass man deswegen sagt,
wir brauchen keine Ziele. Aber ich glaube,
wir brauchen etwas Optimismus. Und wir müssen
uns Gedanken machen, wie wir dann
Stück für Stück diese Ziele
eben nachschärfen können,
um sie auch verlässlich zu halten.
Ich glaube aber, dass man, weil du gesagt
hast, wir müssen sehr, sehr schnell
handeln: 1,5 Grad. Wenn man
das 1,5-Grad-Ziel komplett auf die USA
anwenden würde, dann müsste man in drei
Jahren dort komplett auf Null
sein. Ich glaube, das schafft man nicht.
So Melanie ist die ganze Zeit
hin- und hergelaufen, sowohl bei Carla
als auch bei dir.
Also wo stehst du gerade?
Dass die Politik vor allen Dingen
auf Technologien setzt, hat oft auch damit
zu tun, dass da so ein Optimismus
herrscht. Man hat das Gefühl,
Technologie kann alle Probleme
lösen, weil es ist auch schön einfach. Sobald
die Technologie da ist, sind alle
Probleme weg. Es ist aber meistens nicht so.
Viele Technologien haben auch einen
ziemlichen Rattenschwanz. Der Kulturwandel
ist vielleicht etwas, was langfristiger
wirkt. Den haben wir aber eigentlich
schon, also wir haben schon
seit vielen Jahren eine hohe Zustimmung
zu Klimaschutzzielen, wir haben eine sehr umweltbewusste
Bevölkerung. Das heißt
nicht, dass jeder umweltbewusst
handelt, aber sozusagen im Bewusstsein ist
das schon angekommen. Das Problem ist
aber, dass häufig ein Widerspruch erlebt
wird. Also man hält sich selbst
vielleicht an etwas, hat aber das Gefühl, die anderen
machen ja gar nicht mit. Dann hat
man das Gefühl, ich kann überhaupt nichts
verändern, ich habe nicht genug
Selbstwirksamkeit. Oder ich selber
versuche, auf Fleisch zu verzichten,
aber gleichzeitig ist das Fleisch so ultra
billig, es kostet drei Euro das Kilo,
ist sogar billiger als Gemüse, dass man
das Gefühl hat, was mache ich denn
eigentlich hier? Und deswegen zieht man
sich halt zurück, man macht dann halt
das, was man immer macht, man pflegt dann
-seine Gewohnheiten.
-Dann sagt z.B. Pia, da brauchen wir halt
harte Einschnitte, z.B.
auch mal ein klares Verbot.
Also ich möchte persönlich nicht die Wahl
haben oder die Freiheit haben insofern,
Dinge zu konsumieren, die halt
tatsächlich anderen Menschen ihre Freiheit
auf ein gesundes Leben nehmen. Also es ist
jetzt sehr utopisch gedacht, aber glaubst
du nicht schon, dass so was wie ein Fleischverbot
symbolisieren würde,
was z.B. mit Fleischerzeugung alles
einhergeht? Also ob nicht auch da dann
vielleicht als Aufklärungsmaßnahme
irgendwie erstmal so, wow, was wieso wird
jetzt Fleisch verboten, das muss
ja schon krass schädlich sein für mich,
für die Umwelt, für die Tiere,
für was auch immer. Ob das nicht
auch in dem Moment, ganz was du
gesagt hast, dass man so eine Kultur schafft,
dass Leute schon verstehen, worum
es eigentlich geht, das damit vielleicht
auch erzeugt würde. Und wenn es für alle
verboten würde, wäre es ja auch nicht
ungerecht, weil dann alle
gleichermaßen davon betroffen wären.
Aber wenn du das Fleisch in Deutschland
verbietest, dann haben wir doch damit
-global kein Problem gelöst.
-Das ist ein guter Punkt, ja.
Was du aber in Deutschland
machen könntest, ist - und das passiert,
ich finde, es könnte noch mehr passieren
- dass wir Alternativen schaffen. Ich finde
aber, wenn du heute in den Supermarkt
gehst und siehst, wie viel Alternativen
es zum Fleisch gibt, also vegane
und vegetarische Alternativen, dann ist
das was ganz anderes als das,
was wir vor fünf Jahren erlebt haben.
Und wenn wir dort mehr reinstecken
würden, wenn diese ganzen Food Startups nicht
immer nur amerikanische wären,
sondern vielleicht auch mal europäische
-oder deutsche.
-Ich finde diese Debatte, und das spielt
auch so ein bisschen in diese Frage
des Kulturwandels rein, ist eine pseudo
Debatte und auch gefährlich. Denn
genau die hat uns an diesen Punkt gebracht,
dass die Klimakrise und die Maßnahmen
zur Bekämpfung der Klimakrise so unglaublich
polarisiert behandelt werden
gesellschaftlich. Weil wir so viel über
Individualentscheidungen sprechen, die aber
wenn wir uns mal wirklich realistisch
angucken, dass 100 Konzerne für 71
Prozent der Treibhausgasemissionen weltweit
verantwortlich sind, ist es nicht
mein Burger Patty, meine Plastikzahnbürste
oder irgendwie meine Reise nach Italien,
die für die Klimakrise verantwortlich ist.
Sondern es sind diese 100
Konzerne, die für 71 Prozent der Emissionen
verantwortlich sind. Inmitten der Klimakrise,
im Jahr 2021, können nicht
Banken neue Pipelines finanzieren,
Konzerne neue Erdgaskraftwerke bauen,
denn es ist ganz klar, dass ist nicht
die Zukunft, das sind nicht die Technologien,
die wir brauchen. Und das schafft
ja unglaubliche Pfadabhängigkeiten.
Wenn wir jetzt eine Pipeline bauen,
dann wird dadurch für die nächsten Jahrzehnte
Erdöl gefördert, was unser CO2-Budget
einfach sprengt. Deswegen ist ganz klar,
-so was darf nicht mehr passieren.
-Und das hat euch, Philipp, dich hat es
-offenbar überzeugt.
-Das Argument auf jeden Fall, ja. Jetzt kam
wieder Fleischkonsum verbieten. Ich hab
da auch eine andere Sichtweise zu. Wir haben
Landwirtschaftsysteme, wenn wir jetzt
die Viecher auf die Weide stellen, da haben
wir auf einmal eigentlich keine
Methanemissionen mehr. Wenn wir Walweide
und Rotationsweide
kombinieren, dann überkompensieren Wiederkäuer
ihre klimaschädlichen
Treibhausgasemissionen. Das heißt
Weideviehhaltung mit einem
richtigen Management wäre also potenziell
eine Kohlenstoffsenke
oder eine Treibhausgassenke. Aber
in der Öffentlichkeit heißt es,
Fleisch verbieten. Das andere ist z.B.
wenn ich mir angucke, Deutschland
verbraucht für Videostreaming so viel
Energie wie die ganze Volkswirtschaft
von Spanien. Also da würde ich doch vielleicht
Videostreaming einfach mal
verbieten, YouTube verbieten. Ich glaube du bist
-YouTububerin.
-Ja.
Ja, das ist so der Punkt, es ist
wahnsinnig komplex und das ist auch das,
was du sagst, als Individuum ist man
da total verloren. Und Verbote sind oft
-auch kontraproduktiv.
-Also ich würde schon zustimmern, dass mit
Sicherheit Verbote, die nicht gut
genug durchdacht sind, dann halt genau
das Gegenteil bewirken. Das ist
ultra gefährlich. Deswegen bräuchte es ja
auch richtig viele Menschen mit richtig
viel Ahnung, um wirklich zu gucken,
welche Verbote machen denn
tatsächlich Sinn. Da musst du dich halt auch fragen,
das kann nicht einfach über die Menschen,
die es am meisten betrifft,
-hinweg entschieden werden.
-Es gibt ja auch Formate wie z.B. die
Bürgerräte, wo eben alle möglichen
Leute gefragt werden, wo ein informierter
Prozess stattfindet mit allen
möglichen Fachleuten in der Beteiligung, sodass
wir gute Lösungen erarbeiten können und sie aber
gemeinsam erarbeiten und sie dann
aber auch von allen getragen werden.
Und das, denke ich, ist wirklich nachhaltig.
Das ist wiederum ein Plädoyer für eine Demokratisierung
der Demokratie,
-wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
-Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Vor allen Dingen mehr Empowerment
und mehr Bottom-Up-Prozesse. Also das,
was wir eigentlich brauchen, ist, dass wir nicht
sozusagen in elitären Kreisen über
Verbote oder erwünschtes und unerwünschtes
Handeln sprechen, sondern eben viel mehr
demokratische Prozesse haben, in denen
solche Aushandlungen regional und lokal
-stattfinden.
-Also wir sind da auf einem unglaublich
hohen Ross und glauben, wir haben uns
wahnsinnig entwickelt und reduzieren schon
unsere Emissionen. Aber einen
Großteil geben wir einfach auch ab. Diese schöne
neue Technikwelt bei uns
heißt letztendlich, in China fallen
die Emissionen an, da werden die Solarzellen
produziert und dann vielleicht
auch noch die Elektroautos. Und das Zweite,
was da mit dranhängt, ist einfach
eine unglaubliche Ungerechtigkeit.
Und das haben wir hier bei uns im Land auch,
wenn es um Arbeitsplätze geht. Da hab
ich ein Problem, wenn wir sagen, wir verbieten
jetzt den Kohleabbau und dann sind
die Leute arbeitslos. Aber wir müssen uns
einfach eine andere Frage stellen:
Die Frage ist, ist Arbeit überhaupt das,
an das Existenzsicherung gekoppelt
sein kann? Also Klimaschutz geht eigentlich
nur mit einem völlig
anderen Gesellschaftsmodell.
Also ich denke, was total wichtig
ist, ist sich darüber zu unterhalten,
einen gesellschaftlichen
Aushandlungsprozess dazu zu haben,
was eigentlich Lebensqualität ist.
Und diese Vorstellung von Lebensqualität
verändert sich ja sehr stark. Und gerade
sind von vielen Menschen die Vorstellungen
von Lebensqualität gekoppelt an Konsum,
der aber im Endeffekt eigentlich was ist,
das nur kurzzeitig zufrieden
stellt. Also die Lebensqualitätforschung zeigt
eigentlich am wichtigsten ist für Menschen,
dass sie soziale Interaktionen
haben, dass sie Selbstwirksamkeit
erfahren, dass sie das Gefühl haben,
sie können ihr Leben
bestimmen. Und dass sie ihren Vorstellungen
nach auch ihre Zukunft entwickeln
können, also eine Zukunftsaussicht und das gerade
-wird einem mit dem Klimawandel genommen.
-Wie geht ihr jetzt mit Menschen um, ich
fange mal an Grün, die sich das jetzt
anhören und sagen: Okay, da fiel das Wort
Fleischverbot, da fiel das Wort
Verbrennerverbot, wahrscheinlich wird
mein Strom teurer und ich habe Angst
um meinen Job. Und jetzt erklärt ihr mir,
wir sollen jetzt noch mehr
harte Einschnitte haben? Was antwortet
-ihr solchen ZuschauerInnen?
-Ich glaube, wir müssen einmal noch
sozusagen wirklich bei der Realität
anfangen, was sind die Folgen
der Klimakrise, die uns hier erwarten,
die es schon gibt, die es auch hier schon
gibt? Also wenn wir uns auch die Sommer
angucken, kannst du sicherlich irgendwie
am besten bestätigen, gerade
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte sehen schon heute die Folgen
der Klimakrise durch die größten Dürren
in Europa seit Jahrhunderten. Also das glaub
ich nochmal klarzumachen, was bedeutet
das eigentlich, ist das Eine. Und dann ist
die zweite Frage, glaube ich, eine ganz
essentielle Diskursfrage. Wir müssen
darüber sprechen, was passiert mit Leuten,
deren Arbeitsplätze tatsächlich bedroht
sind durch Klimaschutzmaßnahmen. Wie können
wir dafür sorgen, dass Regionen,
in denen Strukturwandel stattfinden
muss, mitgenommen werden. Dass wir Perspektiven
schaffen. Aber nicht die Aufgabe, die wir haben,
die so essentiell ist, der wir uns
auch völkerrechtlich verpflichtet
haben mit der Unterschrift des Pariser
Klimaabkommens, die nicht einfach
zu verneinen. Und ich glaube, darüber
den Diskurs zu führen, anstatt
generell Abstand zu halten von dem Ziel, weil man
sagt, nö das wollen wir jetzt nicht.
Das wäre total wichtig, um den Diskurs dann so
zu führen, dass wir als Gesellschaft
darüber diskutieren können, wie wollen
-wir denn alle mitnehmen.
-Da würde ich genau da einhaken.
-Ja, bitte.
-Wenn wir dann einen demokratischen Prozess
führen und sagen, was wollen wir denn
fördern, was müssen wir vielleicht
verbieten, dann haben wir unglaublich
viele Hebel in der Hand. Und dann können
wir sagen, wir können uns um den Kulturwandel
kümmern und jetzt können
wir ganz, ganz konkret das und das machen.
Und das ist etwas, wo ich einfach
persönlich sagen muss, in der Landwirtschaft
hätten wir da einen
Riesenhebel, wenn das Geld da wäre
und das gesellschaftliche Interesse,
da was zu machen. Und da können
wir sagen, wir können durch Bäume,
durch Wiederbegrünung der Welt ganz,
ganz viel abfangen, wir können uns Zeit
verschaffen. Das ist sozusagen das,
was die UN diese Nature Based Solutions
nennen, mit naturbasierten
Methoden arbeiten. Da haben wir einen
Riesenpotenzial, um ganz
kurzfristig zu sagen, wir hauen einen Stopp rein
-bei der Klimaerwärmung.
-Wir haben jetzt über verschiedene, nicht
ganz ernst gemeinte
Verbotsvorschläge gesprochen. Es wird in der nächsten
Zukunft hier kein Fleischverbot in Deutschland
geben. Hast du denn überhaupt
den Eindruck, dass man mit harten
Einschnitten in Deutschland z.B.
-weltweit etwas lösen kann?
-Wir leben in Deutschland und wir haben
erst einmal Verantwortung für uns und für unser Land
und damit dienen wir schon
als Vorbild, wenn wir das schon
erreichen. Das heißt, es wird mitwirken. Es löst
natürlich nicht das komplette
Problem, aber wir dienen als Vorbilder und sind
vielleicht ein Best-Practice-Beispiel
und andere können sich dadurch ein Vorbild
-nehmen und das Gleiche machen.
-Jetzt sagt natürlich vielleicht der ein
oder andere, warum soll ich denn jetzt
hier noch ökologischer denken als sowieso
schon? Vielleicht sogar noch weniger
Fleisch essen, während die Amis da drüben
mit ihren dicken Karren durch die Gegend
fahren? Also ganz ehrlich, da hab
ich keine Lust
drauf, ist doch total unfair.
Naja, man kann die Diskussion ja
anders führen. Deswegen bin ich auch einen
Schritt nach vorn gegangen, weil du
hast ja gesagt, wir können ein Beispiel dafür
sein, dass sich andere an uns
orientieren können. Und das ist ja unsere Aufgabe.
Also zwei Prozent CO2-Ausstoß dafür
sind wir in Deutschland verantwortlich,
-weltweit.
-Für ein Prozent der Weltbevölkerung.
Viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft. Und wenn wir zeigen,
dass wir das machen können,
im laufenden Betrieb so ein Land zu erneuern
- und dass CO2-freie Produkte ja
nicht unbedingt schlechtere sein müssen,
es können auch bessere sein, beim Auto
werden es bessere sein - dann
werden sich andere an uns orientieren.
Wir reden ja hier tatsächlich
über wahrscheinlich auch Einschnitte
in eine Gesellschaft. Wir können ja
nicht drumherum reden, auch wenn du sagst,
-Wohlstand würdest du gerne erhalten.
-Müssen wir erhalten.
Dann müssen wir uns aber fragen, wie wir Wohlstand
definieren. Weil ich glaube,
Wohlstand wird ja ganz, ganz viel
immer noch gemessen als Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Und wenn wir uns mal angucken, was das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
oder generell viele
volkswirtschaftliche Indikatoren, die so
funktionieren, bilden ja überhaupt gar
nicht tatsächlichen
gesellschaftlichen Wohlstand ab. Der DAX steigt
während der Coronakrise auf neue
Höchstwerte, gleichzeitig sind 100.000
Leute in Kurzarbeit, Kinder können
nicht zur Schule gehen, Leute können ihre Jobs
nicht ausüben und können nur zu Hause
sitzen, haben keine Sozialkontakte.
Das heißt, wir müssen doch auch anerkennen,
dass Wohlstand viel, viel mehr
als ein Zahlenindikator aus der Wirtschaft
ist. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz,
ganz essentieller Punkt. Wenn wir davon
sprechen, wir wollen Wohlstand erhalten,
dann müssen uns erst mal fragen, was ist
Wohlstand überhaupt? Deswegen gibt's
Länder wie beispielsweise
Neuseeland, die jetzt so etwas eingeführt haben
wie ein Well-Being-Index, also ein Wohlstandsindex,
der Kindererziehung,
auch gesellschaftliche
Ungleichheiten miteinbezieht, der Bildungschancen
miteinbezieht. Um eben zu sagen, wir haben
einen Indikator, der Wohlstand anders
einordnet, als nur anhand von irgendeiner
volkswirtschaftlichen Zahl, die steigen
kann, während es den Leuten
viel schlechter geht.
Ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt etwas erreichen
wollen, dann müssen wir einen Zahn
zulegen. Und wenn man gesehen
hat, wie schnell wir in der Lage sind,
einen Impfstoff zu entwickeln, dann
zeigt das doch, was für eine Power in den Leuten
steckt. Wenn der Rahmen klar
definiert ist, dann machen sich die Leute
auf den Weg und sagen, ich kann
damit Geld verdienen, ich kann damit
meine Arbeitsplätze sichern und ich kann
auch ein gutes Leben führen. Und von mir
aus sollen sie auch ein großes
Haus danach bauen. Es ist alles gut.
Also du redest die ganze Zeit
davon, Wohlstand muss erhalten bleiben,
wir brauchen weiter Fortschritt.
Aber mal angenommen, dass wirklich weniger
von allem wirklich effektiv wäre,
wärst du dann bereit, auch etwas abzugeben?
Würdest du nicht auch Menschen sagen,
dann verzichten wir halt mal auf das, mal
auf das und mal auf das? Wir haben
trotzdem genug zu essen, ein Dach überm
Kopf, genug zu trinken, leben in einer sicheren
Welt. Wäre's das Wert?
Total richtig, seinen eigenen
Konsum und sein eigenes Verhalten ständig
zu hinterfragen und zu überlegen,
muss dieses T-Shirt sein, muss diese Jeans
sein, brauche ich das zehnte Paar
Sneaker oder brauche ich es nicht? Aber es ist
eine individuelle Entscheidung, die will
ich nicht für irgendjemanden abnehmen.
Das würde ja für dich bedeuten können,
wenn jetzt nicht auf individueller Ebene,
sondern halt wirtschaftlich, politisch
was entschieden wird, dass das dann für dich
am Ende heißt: Okay, du kannst dann
nicht mehr jeden Tag Auto fahren, Fleisch essen,
etc., Streaming angucken. Das ist ja
etwas, was Carla gesagt hat, es geht nicht
darum, was du darfst oder nicht,
sondern was im Endeffekt bei rumkommt.
Wenn wir halt krasse Maßnahmen, die wir dringend
brauchen, jetzt politisch
entscheiden lassen, dass wir dann
vielleicht am Ende weniger von unserem
Wohlstand behalten
können, wäre das nicht okay?
Wir haben ja ein System, was einen
ganz klaren Rahmen in Richtung CO2-Neutralität
gesteckt hat. Das heißt, jeder Mensch,
der irgendein Produkt anbietet, wird sich
jetzt die Frage stellen: Wie geht es auch CO2-neutral?
Und wenn du dir den CO2-Preis
und seine Entwicklung anguckst, dann
werden diejenigen, die das nicht schaffen,
-nicht mehr existieren können.
-Ich glaube, wir sind einigermaßen klar
geworden, wer wo steht. Ich glaube,
die Trennlinien sind auch deutlich geworden.
Darum geht es ja bei dieser Sendung
auch, dass wir überhaupt wissen, was vereint uns
und was trennt uns. Ich würde gerne mal
zum Abschluss kommen, zu einer sogenannten
Kompromissrunde. Ich würde einen
Vorschlag machen, in der Hoffnung, dass ihr da alle
zustimmt und alle ein Schritt nach vorne
gehen könnt. Ihr könnt auch sagen, was ist
denn das für ein komischer Vorschlag,
bleib ich lieber stehen. Und danach seid
ihr in euren Gruppen aufgefordert,
einen Vorschlag zu formulieren, der die andere
Seite zu euch holt. Ich glaube, ihr würdet
vielleicht alle einen Schritt vorgehen,
wenn ich sage, die Weiterverteilung
von schlechtem Gewissen
an EndverbraucherInnen, also Shaming
als Überbegriff, hilft uns dauerhaft nicht
weiter. Wir müssen in jedem Fall
politisch vorgehen und nicht so sehr an einzelne
KonsumentInnen herantreten. Sind wir uns
da einig? Große Schritte nach vorne,
alle im Kompromissbereich. So, jetzt
seid ihr dran, ihr dürft jetzt mal kurz
die Köpfe zusammenstecken,
Corona-konform innerhalb eurer Gruppen und überlegen.
Kurze Zeit gebe ich euch, ob es eine Formulierung
gibt, einen Satz gibt,
wo ihr glaubt, die anderen kommen
auf uns zu, bitteschön. So, das wird jetzt
spannend, ob es am Ende eine Kompromissrunde
gibt. Was haben wir noch
vergessen? Habt ihr vielleicht eine Idee,
wie diese beiden Gruppen irgendwie näher
aufeinander zubewegt werden
können? Da wäre ich sehr gespannt. Wunderbar.
Wir stehen alle wieder
beisammen. Wie sieht es aus? Gruppe Gelb? Habt
ihr irgendetwas, was ihr den anderen
sagen würdet, wo die vielleicht sogar noch einen
-Schritt näher zu euch kommen?
-Ja, eine gute Mischung haben wir.
Also wir sind dafür,
Verpflichtungen einzuführen und zwar sozialökologische
Bilanzierungen für Unternehmen,
Organisationen und Institutionen,
um die sozialökologische
Transformation voran zu bringen. Heißt nicht ein Verbot,
sondern eine Verpflichtung zur Bilanzierung
im sozialökologischen Sinne.
Wir wollen mehr Transparenz haben, was die Nachvollziehbarkeit
der Transformation
betrifft, also auch die Frage nicht
nur wie ist ein Produkt, sondern wo kommt's
her? Wo kommen seine Bestandteile
her? Unter welchen Bedingungen?
Ich will jetzt erst mal wissen,
ob die drei da drüben jetzt da mitgehen
und sagen: Ja, klingt gut. Oder ob ihr sagt:
Das ist irgendwie Quatsch.
Ja, aber natürlich nicht als einziger
Ansatz, als einzige Lösung. Aber
eine Möglichkeit, die auf jeden
Fall was bringen würde.
Habt ihr auch einen
Vorschlag, eine Formulierung?
Ja, wir haben es ein bisschen
allgemeiner formuliert. Mal angenommen,
nach ausreichender
wissenschaftlicher Beratung und allen mit einbezogen,
die davon betroffen sind, würde
irgendwann langfristig ein Verbot in Kraft treten,
was aber zu 100 Prozent dafür
sorgt, dass wirklich weniger Menschen
unter der Klimakrise leiden werden.
Dann wärt ihr bereit, das Verbot auch so
-zu unterzeichnen –Fragezeichen?
-Habt ihr irgendetwas im Kopf gehabt, ein
Beispiel? Es muss
jetzt nicht genau das sein.
Zum Beispiel sowas wie der Kohleausstieg
ist eigentlich ein Beispiel dafür,
ein Gasausstieg langfristig. Wir haben
ja auch drüber gesprochen, es gibt so viele
Verbote, die niemand irgendwie
kritisch findet oder Vorgaben. Jeder von uns
schnallt sich im Auto, wenn er Auto
fährt, sicherlich an, was auch mal Leute
irgendwie den totalen Aufreger
fanden. Und genau dasselbe halt auch.
-Geht ihr mit?
-Ja, wenn damit der Kohleausstieg gemeint
ist, dann würde ich es unterschreiben.
Aber nur dann, wenn es vor 2038 passiert.
Ja gut, ich glaube, damit seid ihr d'accord.
Wunderbar, ganz herzlichen Dank.
Es hat großen Spaß gemacht. Wie immer
in dieser Diskussion wird es nicht so sein,
dass am Ende alle mit einer tollen
Lösung für die Planetenrettung nach Hause gehen,
aber vielleicht mit ein bisschen mehr
Verständnis und auch die Frage, was heißt
eigentlich Verbot. Deswegen finde ich euren
letzten Kompromissvorschlag auch gar
nicht so schlecht, mal drüber
nachzudenken, das Verbot nicht per se
negativ sein muss. Schließlich ist es uns
auch verboten, bei Rot über die Ampel
zu gehen zum Beispiel. Das haben wir auch irgendwie
akzeptiert. Vielen, vielen Dank.
-Das waren 13 Fragen.
-Ja, wir haben über Verbote in dem Sinne
gesprochen, dass es um Richtungsentscheidungen
für bestimmte
Lösungen geht. Ich glaube, dass wir diesen Streit,
den wir auch geführt haben,
dass wir den intensiver führen
müssen, dass wir den auch als Gesellschaft
intensiver führen müssen, weil nur dadurch
können Lösungen entstehen.
Ich glaube, gerade dieses gesamtgesellschaftliche
Bewusstsein
für Klimagerechtigkeit, dass das gestiegen
ist in den letzten Jahren, ist etwas,
was mir Hoffnung gibt. Die leeren
Versprechungen, die uns teilweise
Unternehmen mit Greenwashing-Kampagnen
und PolitikerInnen in ihren Wahlprogrammen
machen, das ist
nicht das, was mir Mut gibt,
wenn ich auf dieses Bundestagswahljahr
schaue. Sondern es sind die Menschen,
die ich tagtäglich bei Friday for
Future, aber auch woanders erlebe, die mir
Hoffnung geben. Denn ich sehe immer
wieder und wieder und die letzten Jahre haben
es auch bewiesen, die Veränderung kommt
aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft.